- [Gabriel] My name is Gabriel Paredes.
I'm based in Bogota, Colombia.
I'm a Solution Architect for
the financial services industry
and I've been in the company
for the last seven years
in which I had the privilege
to support many customers
as within Latin America
in the use of Agentic
AI for their business
and in this case Intel,
artificial intelligence.
And with me is...
- [Luis] Hi there. Happy to be here.
My name is Luis Eduardo Torres
and a Solutions Architect Manager
for financial sector industry in Colombia.
And I have been working for
AWS almost six years, mainly,
helping in different kind of services,
but very interested in
analytics and GenAI.
So now that we tell you
more details about us,
we would like to know more about you.
So, we are going to
personalize the session.
So the first task for today
is if you can help us,
we are going to have an small
survey just to know what is,
is your knowledge about Agentic AI
and the AWS services
and that will allow us
to personalize this session.
So it should take two or
three minutes to complete,
the five questions that we have here.
So let me switch to my screen.
(presenter speaks indistinctly)
The QR is working.
Can someone confirm it's working fine.
- [Audience Member] Perfect.
- [Luis] Okay. So we have 27 participants.
We are going to give 20 seconds more
and then we are going to
start with a few questions.
36.
10 seconds more.
Let's go. All right, let's go.
So the first question
that we have for you is,
have you deployed any AI agents
in a production environment?
Yes or no?
So, we have 50/50.
- [Gabriel] 50/50. Okay.
- [Luis] Okay, very good. Next question.
What are the main challenges you had faced
when deploying agents to production?
It's cause of cost, precision,
latency, integration.
What's the main issue that you have seen?
Precision, okay.
And integration, okay.
That will work for what
we have prepared today.
Next, have you worked with the Strands?
We know that maybe you have heard a lot of
about the Strands these days,
but we want to know more
if you have already used it
or if you are using different frameworks,
which is fine, we are
going to talk about it,
but just to know.
So we have 25% of the people
that already have used Strands.
We are going to show you here
some things about the Strands.
Very good.
Have you used AgentCore
or other agent frameworks?
Ah or more than other
frameworks is more related
to other services related
to AWS for Agentic,
but that's fine.
Let me check.
How many of you already
know about AgentCore? 29.
So more than 50%.
Okay, we are going to show
some interesting things there.
And finally the last two questions.
Which observability tools do you use
for monitoring your agents?
Are you using AgentCore
Observability or Langfuse,
Langsmith?
Other?
Only two people here have been using
AgentCore Observability.
That's why we have this
session to show you
what you can do there.
It's very good Langsmith,
Langfuse and other,
a lot of people in other.
Okay.
And finally the last question.
We told you that we are from
Colombia so we want to know
if you already know where
is Colombia is located.
Some people confuse our
country with the state.
So actually it's different
how you can write both words.
24. Ah, there is a lot of doubts here.
Less people 36. Okay, very good.
- [Gabriel] So you gave it
that a little bit more of time.
(Luis chuckles)
- [Luis] Yeah, definitely
someone is winter.
Okay, okay. North of
South America. Very good.
Central America. No. I don't know.
Very good, thank you.
So yeah,
Columbia is in the north of South America.
Okay, thank you very
much for your answers.
That's a way as we want
to know more about you
so we can customize the
content of the session.
The agenda that we have prepared for today
is start talking about AgentCore
and talking about observability
and why this is important.
Also, we are going to
build, this is a code talk.
So most of the time we are
being building an agent.
We already have an agent
with different issues
and we need your help
to improve the issues that we have there.
And finally we are going
to share some resources,
that can be useful for you.
So if you mention that 50%
of the people here mention
that already has agents in production,
in case you don't have good observability,
there can be different mistakes
or different bad
behaviors with the agents.
So what we want to
achieve with this session
is that more people know about
how to use the AWS services
to improve the visibility of the agents
that you are deploying in production.
So we have as a goal when
when we have observability,
we are looking for a way to control
the non-deterministic behaviors
that we have with foundational models.
Basically you can have an agent
that is providing different answers
to each a customer, to each user.
So we want to know what's happening.
Also, sometimes the companies
are deploying agents
in production to achieve
a business objective,
like for example increase the revenue,
but that's not happening.
So we need to have more visibility
to know what happened there.
Eh, the other thing
that we are going to see
during the demonstration is
that these systems are complex.
So we have different
system knowledge bases,
we have different NCPs
that are integrated there
and we need a way to know
what is causing, for example,
problems with precision or with latency.
So with that said,
what we are building today is
a case that we already have
in Colombia with a customer.
They want to create a financial advisor.
So this financial
advisor has for this case
and we are going to be working on that,
has chat where the customers
can ask for a new credit
for a new loan and obtain information
about if the customer is
eligible for a credit,
if the customer has a good behavior
or performance for the bank, a good score.
Also we are going to verify
how what can be the rate
for the credit and more information.
So Gabriel or Gabo, I'm
gonna call you Gabo,
it's cool how I call you in Colombia.
So Gabo, do you know what kind of issues
we have right now with this agent?
- [Gabriel] Yes, I have
seen with many of situations
when deploying agents into
production that they become
like a black box for
some of our customers.
And basically there are a
couple of issues related.
One to the evolve ability
of the architecture.
Like for example, we need
to move from one model
to a newer model and we
don't have the right tools
to measure if the quality of
the responses are improving
or decreasing compared
to the previous model.
We are also see situations
in which the prompts
might be contradictory and the tool use
becomes a little bit nuanced
because some the instructions
can be overlapped.
I have seen other situations
in which the integration
with external tools are not clear
and basically the there is not a way
to identify why the agent
is taking a decision
and what is reasoning
to use a specific path
like for example in a
multi-agent architecture.
Okay.
- [Luis] Okay, very good.
So we have all those kind of issues today
and with your help we
are going to improve it.
But before going further,
you mentioned that some of
you know about AgentCore.
So why AgentCore is
important for this project
that we are doing here?
- [Gabriel] Now, with
AgentCore we are looking
for all of our customers
to move away from POC,
from mass POC to
production with confidence.
Basically AgentCore allows to build,
to focus on building the Agentic part
to building the specific agents
and not worrying about the
hosting the infrastructure.
AgentCore is building in a modular way
or in a component mindset in
which you can implement each
individual components
individually based on the needs
of your specific agents, okay?
And that also renders basically
into reducing the time to market.
Basically you can start building
and let AgentCore to take most
of the responsibility in
hosting the infrastructure
and also the integration.
You have the integration
with native services
and also with third party tools
for logging and monitoring.
- [Luis] Very good AgentCore
has different components
that work individually.
So if you prefer only go
by one, you can do it.
In the case of observability,
if you already are using other frameworks
or if you are also right now
using a different platform
to deploy your agents
for example EKS or ECS,
but you want to use
observability, you can do it.
So for today we are
going to focus on a run
Amazon AgentCore for the side runtime
and we are going to have
also the observability.
Those are the main components
that we are going to use today.
But something that I also
want to let you know is that,
this is enabled for different frameworks.
So you want to have
different, not only Strands
but other frameworks
running in the wrong time.
That's possible.
Or if you have a different kind of
observability tools
and you want to support
all this information there that's possible
because we are using OpenTelemetry.
So what we are going
to have in the console
is first a chat agent where our customers
can ask different questions
about a financial credit or loan.
Then we are going to use Strands
to define an agent and multi-agent.
That Strands agent has the capabilities
to integrate with different tools
and also we have created
an agent flow there
and also we have some knowledge basis
to answer questions to our customers.
So all these flow you
are going to see in it,
we want to you to know this,
we are going to integrate also
with different external tools
and the agent that we have here,
it's gonna be running in AgentCore running
and the idea that we can see logs,
metrics and traces using
AgentCore Observability.
So at the end of the
session we should improve
all the issues that we have
right now with the agent,
but also we are going to
have the possibility of
or see everything that is
happening in a dashboard
with a lot of detail.
So let's build.
- [Gabriel] So let's start
and as Luis mentioned,
we will require your help
and also to help us build
and fix this, the issues in this agent.
So we're going to be iterating over
the agent that's already running
and if you can switch to the coiner.
Well first question, can you see the code?
- [Luis] You should-
- [Gabriel] Okay, let me make
it up a little bit bigger.
(presenter speaks indistinctly)
Settings.
And settings and let me find
font increase a little bit.
Font size.
I think that should be better. Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Luis] This is better.
- [Gabriel] I think so. Perfect.
Now, we're going to start with a,
I will say a fast run over
what is built in this moment.
So we have in this section an agent
that is built on the
strand, SDK as we mentioned.
And it basically, it's composed like a,
like we say a simple structure.
We have at the top of
the agent all the imports
for our models we have the configuration
for the environment variables.
In order to set the prompts
and to set the the the models,
you can see there are some of the things
that we're going to be solving
during the presentation.
We have a couple of utilities
for grabbing the prompts
from the prompt management
because the prompts are not
embedded directly into the code.
And basically we have two tools,
one for the calculating the loans
and basically retaining
the monthly payments.
And we have a tool
for retrieving information
from a knowledge base.
Okay?
And then we have the
creation of the four agents.
I'm going to open one
of those so you can see
because the pattern is almost the same.
So we have a declaration of
the model that we are using,
some parameters.
Then we have the agent
as we create the agent
and provide the tools and
then we return the agent back
to a single orchestration
point in which we fix
and stitch all together
into a swarm architecture.
A swarm architecture for agents,
it's like a full mesh of
communication between the agents.
So we have an entry point
which is the orchestrator
and then the orchestrator is responsible
for handing over the transition
to other agents autonomously
in order to solve an issue.
So as you can see we have one agent
that can check the rates
based on the documentation.
We have an agent that is a specialist
in doing a loan interest
rate calculations.
We have one agent that
can check for eligibility
and we have an agent that
basically they responsible
for orchestrating everything.
Okay so far, any questions?
No. Perfect.
So the first thing is
that I wanted to show you
is that this agent is already
running in Strands SDK
and running in Strands runtime,
I'm sorry, in AgentCore runtime.
So with the quick start
and the quick start from AgentCore,
you can deploy agents easily.
Basically you configure the
utility to grab the code,
to grab the dependencies,
to set the features
that you want to enable,
like for example,
memory observability enabled
by default, by the way.
If you want to change where the traces
and the logs are being stored
and once the agent is
deployed you can check it
with AgentCore command, AgentCore status
and you can start seeing like
when was the agent created
in which account it's running,
what's the runtime ID,
the deployment time,
this was deployed last time was deployed
today in the afternoon.
And finally you're going to see
this handy command that it's here.
Have you ever seen this command before?
No.
First time?
Well this command, it's
part of the AWS CLI.
Basically it's for CloudWatch logs
and this is a teal command that allow us
to basically follow the
logs as we invoke our agent.
This is not a functionality
exclusive for a AgentCore.
It's basically for every log group
that you have in your account,
you can like an all unique system,
I will say like, tail a log
file in front an Apache Server
that's the same that you can do
with a CloudTrail, CloudWatch logs.
Okay, so I'm going to copy
and paste that command
because that's the first
observability point
that we have with a AgentCore.
Let me copy and paste this part
and we will have a tale of commands.
Okay.
Now we are not going to
see anything right now
because we don't have any vocations
in our agency at this moment.
But let's switch to our
or to our agent user interface.
So this is something
that we build for this,
for this session specifically
it's a pretty basic,
user interface build on a
streamlet that allows us
to select the AgentCore
runtime and also the version.
As you can see we have made a couple
of testing in version 27
and then we're going to fire a prompt.
Let's see what happened.
So, what are the current
more rates for a 30 year
fixed it long
and then we wait.
Have you experienced something
like this with your agents?
I mean response times super elevated.
- [Luis] What should be the normal time
for an agent is to respond.
What the time that you are
expecting to have an answer?
Less than 10 seconds, less than five?
What do you think?
- [Audience Member]
Depends on the use case.
- [Luis] Depends on the use case.
But for a normal interaction,
what is a good time?
- [Audience Member] 10 to 30 seconds.
- [Luis] 10 to 20 seconds.
So how long it's taking here right now?
Taking work.
- [Gabriel] You can see right here.
- [Luis] Okay.
- [Gabriel] 13.5 seconds.
Now because we left the
console on the tail locks,
we can see what's going
on behind the scenes
with this AgentCore in vocation.
So you can see this allows to see
when agent call runtime receive a request,
the parameters that are
being sent into the request
and also you start seeing like
the reasoning of the agent.
Like for example, in order
to find information about the mortgages,
I need to question another agent
and then I need to hand
over to the specific area
or the specialized agent
and then that context is
passed to the second agent,
that is the collaborator.
And then the final response is assembled
by the orchestrator agent.
As you can see, everything took 13 seconds
and this is locked directly
by default when you launch
with the quick start on AgentCore.
Okay, now let's try to
find some potential,
I will say hypothesis of
why this is happening.
Okay?
- [Luis] What do you think is happening?
Is there kind of things that you review
what you are having an issue
with latency in Agentic?
Some of the things that you can review
is the prompt for
example, or the variables.
- [Gabriel] Exactly now.
Like for example the prompt
is one something that I,
we have set on purpose in this example,
look at this value temperature.
Now it's quite high
and normally when you
set the temperature high
for any foundational model,
the model becomes more creative
and basically it has a more
probabilistic distribution
of words that's going
to select as the output.
So when we want to make
the model a little bit more
constrained in the probabilities,
we could set the temperature back,
like 0.5 or even 0.2.
When we want to make it more strict,
there are some use cases like
for example we might set it
to zero when we want like a prompt router
or to have like a conversion
from text to (indistinct)
or other structure format
because we don't want
creativity in that part.
The other parameter, it's
about the max tokens.
So max tokens allows to control
the length of the response from the LLM.
So in this case we set 400 tokens
but we can decrease that,
yeah to a lower value
because we know that the responses
are not going to be that long.
Okay, what about this,
what do you think about this
configuration right here?
- [Audience Member] It depends,
what kind of model you wanted
to use (speaks faintly).
- [Gabriel] Exactly.
- [Audience Member] Might
be a (speaks faintly),
- [Gabriel] That's important.
And this is kind of funny because we refer
to Anthropic Claude 3.7 like an old model,
but I mean things move super
fast in the GenAI space.
The reality is that there are newer models
that we can implement
and to take advantage.
For example, Nova 2 which
was released just yesterday
and also, Sonnet 4.5.
And also another pattern
that is quite useful
when we have a multi-agent
orchestrated system
is that we can have like a super,
I would say a more optimized
model for the orchestrator
and then we can have a
more specialized model
for the specific agent.
So we're going to roll this
change through this agent
and then we're going to push
the change into production, okay?
The first thing that I'm going
to do is to clean all the,
I will say parameters of
invocation of the agent.
I'm going to set everything
to 0.5 on the temperature,
0.5
and even in the orchestrator
I'm going to set it
like a quite low value like
0.1 because we don't have much,
we don't want much
creativity in that part.
Okay?
The second thing, we are going to set some
of the environment variables
to use the new model.
So this project I have
built with AgentCore
basically relies on a
environment, environments,
variables, external
variables with this file.
So basically I can change
the model right here
in order to grade the model.
So let me open my terminal once again
and let me see and check for that model.
Okay, so AWS.
AWS Bedrock list profiles.
List inference profiles.
Okay, now inference profiles,
it's a mechanism that we
have in order to select
like for example cross region invocation
or cross region in cross
region invocation for models.
So basically we use the
capacity of multiple regions
for a single model and we're going to look
for the endpoint of a Haiku 4.5.
Then we're going to grab this value here.
That is us Anthropic Claude 4.5.
Okay, let me grab this one
and let me place it
right here like Bedrock
or orchestrator model
we're going to add on new variable, okay?
And let me see for the
other ones, Sonnet 4.5.
Okay, and this is the endpoint.
- [Luis] So we are using
an inference profile
because it's better for resilience
in case something happen
in one specific region
and having more capacity
case is needed.
- [Gabriel] That might,
that's one of the reason also
to have enough capacity
because we are distributing,
well the service is
distributing the inference code
to our model replica in each
of the regions we can scale in capacity.
Okay?
Now I have said that the
environment variables,
now I need to roll this
changes into the code.
So I'm going to copy
this environment variable
and I'm going to add a new one.
Orchestrator model.
Now there we are,
and finally we're going to
set this change into the,
lemme close it right here.
Let's create that into
the orchestrator model.
Orchestrator model.
Okay, so basically we modified
to use Haiku on the orchestrator,
which is a lighter model
compared to Sonnet,
which allow us to gain a little bit
of time in the first response.
And then we are operating
the model from 3.7
to 0.5 in the rest of the models.
Okay?
Now we are ready to roll
this change into production
and the way we do that is
with the same AgentCore specification
and the same AgentCore utility.
Agent.
The status, as you can see,
we already have the agent running,
I have an A utility babe for the sake
of this workshop that
basically use a make file
to deploy the agent.
So let me also roll this change here.
This is not what (speaks faintly).
- [Luis] So here we're using the AgentCore
toolkit that allow us to deploy
and simplify the deploy of
new agents in production.
If you haven't used it,
we are going to show you
the resource so you can access this.
I was testing it different times
and you can deploy an agent
in the less than five minutes.
So it's pretty easy.
So the changes that
Gabo has completed here,
we can now send in to the new version
of the agent in the wrong time
we are going to see the new version.
- [Gabriel] I know why
we don't need that much.
It's a little bit
annoying when it tries to,
to recommend blocks of code
that you need actually.
(Gabriel laughs)
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
Okay, but I think we are set,
we have, let me double check.
We have the orchestrator
model, orchestrator model,
then we have orchestrator model
and then we have that into our variables.
Now Let's launch that.
Okay.
Now it took the change
and we have Haiku on the orchestrator,
we have Anthropic model and Sonnet in 4.5.
This is something that it
happened when you might need
to take into consideration,
it happened to me when I
was creating this workshop.
By default, when you launch
an AgentCore, agent base,
you need to pass all the
environmental variables one by one
within the launch command.
If you, it doesn't take the
that end file by default.
So it can go to a like a very difficult,
I will say fault condition
that are difficult to spot bot.
I mean it's part, it's
in the documentation now.
Well it was really quick
and then what it happened,
it's basically it took our project,
it see all the dependencies
that were already running.
It created a, there is
in the local project
a folder that's called
Bedrock AgentCore multi-agent.
And this zip file, as you
can see by the output,
outputs of the lock are
being uploaded to S3
and then it created a deployment package,
OpenTelemetry, salary running.
It's part of the things
that are enabled by default.
And then we have our new agent created.
Now if we will back to our
agent, to our user interface.
Let me refresh this
and we have version 28.
Okay, now let's see the difference.
- [Luis] Oops, okay, there
was a difference there
- [Gabriel] For sure.
(Gabriel laughs)
Let me see once again.
Whoops.
Then refresh a little bit once again.
It should be faster, I promise.
Now while the user interface loading,
we can see that in the locks
what's happening behind the scenes.
Okay, this was the successful invocation
handing over to the new agent handing over
and then there we go.
Now it improve from 30
to 0.5 to 12 seconds.
But we are already seeing
an improvement in this,
in this check, in this aspect.
I mean we can continue to improve it
by making the prompt more specific.
We can make other optimization,
but we're going to get there
in a couple of minutes.
Now, any questions so far within
what we have seen until this moment?
No.
- [Luis] Everything okay.
- [Gabriel] No, let's
try with another one.
Okay, and let me check one second.
No, let me refresh this
user interface once again.
And there we are going to
ask for a different question.
I'm going to check if we
are eligible for a loan.
- [Luis] But Gabo, before going there,
can you please show us the metrics
that we can see in CloudWatch
related to AgentCore?
- [Gabriel] Ah, for sure.
- [Luis] Yeah,
because we were seeing the
latency in the console,
we were seeing that
there are some problems.
But also we want to show you here is
that we have AgentCore Observability
including inside CloudWatch.
So there are different kind
of metrics that will allow us
to improve our agents in the future.
So what we can see here, Gabo.
- [Gabriel] Now we can see right now
that we have two agents
configured, two endpoints.
We have 25 sessions created.
Some of those are created
those with a load test script.
And then we start,
we can start to seeing the
trends in the sessions,
the traces, the errors,
and then we can start seeing like runtime
specific metrics that are quite useful.
Like for example the number of invocation,
the number of BCPU by hour
because that's a unit that
the services charge by.
And also the memory
consumption by gigabytes.
We have two agents right now,
the default and some other
customer support agent
that I created previously.
And we can start to check
a little bit further
for the specific agents, the token usage,
which is also an important
value for capacity planning.
The number of sessions,
the number of traces,
the number of errors
where from the system,
which is for example if
the model failed to import
and also from the client side,
whether it's some parameter misconfigure
or even a header that was misconfigured.
And then we could even have the inbound
and outbound authorization request count.
You know, it's part of the
components of AgentCore.
- [Luis] Something that is
nice about AgentCore run 10
is that you have a serverless environment.
So if you are creating your agents,
you don't have to worry about
any assignment of BCP or memory.
Everything is happening behind the scenes
and is managed by the service.
- [Gabriel] Okay, perfect.
Now we can also invoke the agent
from the AgentCore console.
So, let me show you where you can test.
Within AgentCore service,
you can search for test and agent sandbox
and basically you can select the agent,
the default endpoint in version 28.
And then you can pass,
this is JSON structure
where you can pass your prompt
and also you can pass additional
parameters if you want
or your need like for example,
headers from your application
to give more context about the user.
So I'm going to create
another prompt right now
about the eligibility for a loan.
So, am I (speaks faintly).
- [Luis] So something
that we want to achieve
for this financial
company is that they can
verify if a customer is eligible,
if it's the first time
that this customer is coming to the bank,
that we can have an agent
that verify the user history
and that can confirm what kind of credit
or what kind of loan can
be approved for this user.
- [Gabriel] Okay, now
let's fire this prompt
and let's see the responses.
- [Luis] What was the question?
- [Gabriel] It's checking
if I am eligible for a loan
with a 680 credit score and
a 60K annual income, that's-
- [Luis] In this case the user
is providing directly data.
Most of the time the
companies will verify that.
- [Gabriel] Exactly.
- [Luis] Okay and the answer?
- [Gabriel] And the answer is-
(Gabriel speaks in foreign language)
- [Luis] Many people that
can speak Spanish here?
Okay, very good.
(audience laughs)
- [Gabriel] Now this is
something that can happen.
It's quite common when you
have a multilingual agents,
normally you have like a
specialized prompts based
on the language because
for example in Spanish we,
there are words that have
multiple meanings and we can,
we need to have a more concise prompt
for the specific languages.
It's a good practice and
this can happen. Okay?
Now the thing is that we already saw,
let's go to the code and let's
see what could be happening.
Okay, now let's see where
are our prompts right now?
Let's close this.
Let's close this and let's close this one.
No, it was for eligibility.
So let me search for the
eligibility agent now.
So we have a Bedrock model, a model ID,
a temperature, and then we have a prompt,
basically get prompt an
eligibility agent prompt ID.
Now what's going on behind this scene
for this specific agent, we're
leveraging a functionality
that's called a Amazon
Bedrock Prompt Management,
which is a service that
allows to store version,
I'll say the whole life
cycle of the prompts
in which you can set default parameters
for each of the prompts.
So we need to seek for
the eligibility prompt.
Now if we move to Amazon Bedrock console
as we have previously open here,
as we can see we have the rate checker,
the loan advisor, the Spanish agent,
the eligibility agent, and
the loan calculated agent.
Okay?
So most likely what we
have here is a problem
with the configuration
parameter for our agents.
So let's check what's the
agent ID in this case?
This is L8J.
And let's see in our
environmental variables
.env exactly, that's what we have here.
So the fix is quite simple in this case,
we don't have to modify the
code of the agent itself.
We need to move from one
parameter to another.
So let's seek for this one.
As you can see, you are a
loan advisor especially,
it just says customer qualifications
and recommend blah blah blah blah, blah.
Let's... Let me.
that should be better for you guys
and then let me copy this ID,
the one that ends in 98.
Let me modify that into the
environmental variables.
Okay.
And then I think we're
ready to deploy once again.
- [Luis] So, it was a
problem with the parameter
that someone modified and
left the prone in Spanish.
- [Gabriel] Exactly.
- [Luis] So we are seeing
different customers
implementing multilingual agents,
using multi-agent to allow the customers
to have conversation in the
language that they prefer.
But sometimes it can be useful
to have a specific
parameters for each language,
which is what we have here.
And also the ability
to have the pros there.
We can have the pro inside the code,
but when you have that as a parameter,
you can make more simple the modification
and the new versions
and also having a version of the prompts.
- [Gabriel] It's up once again.
And I want to show a
feature that's quite useful
in this cases that we're testing
and testing constantly
within the AgentCore,
let me grab this prompt before I go in.
Within the AgentCore run
time there is a concept
of endpoint and also about version.
So every version is in multiple.
Once you deploy it, you cannot modify it,
but then you can have multiple endpoints.
It creates one that it's the
default one and it rolls.
The latest version is always
mapped to the default.
But then you can have like
production, pre-production,
Spanish, Latin America, States,
Europe, Spain, Portugal.
You can have many endpoints.
And then on the application
side you can select
which version of the
agent is being invoked.
Okay, now this is version 29.
Just got up recently
and let's test once again
in the Agent sandbox.
Okay, I'm going to fire this invocation
and let me show you once again
the locks because we're now
going to see another aspect
of the observability.
We're going to switch to the traces
so you can see what's going
on with all the visibility.
Now as you can see,
the responses are flowing back in English.
And great news based on your profile
and your current eligibility created,
you are eligible for a personal loan.
Thanks God.
And then we have the invocation
successfully complete.
Now with each invocation
you're going to see
a useful parameter,
which is the session ID.
Okay, session ID is created
by the client is a 30 long character,
normally a unique identified
value that you set
or you can customize the session ID.
But with this session ID, let
me copy and grab this value.
We can go to the observability console
and then we can start to drive on
and to drill down into the
specific of this invocation.
So let me first of all show you a part
that I didn't show at the
beginning of the presentations.
That this functionality of traces uses
what it's called X-Ray traces
that needs to be enabled.
This is in the documentation
of AgentCore Observability.
And basically you need to
enable transactional search
for OpenTelemetry spans.
That's what we are
basically using right here.
This is the open format
for setting the logs in a standard way.
So let me go to the observability
and let me open the sessions.
All sessions.
- [Luis] So every time
that we have a new user,
we have a new session.
- [Gabriel] Exactly.
Even the session can be a set,
it can last for at least 15 minutes
and up to eight hours.
The session can last
for up to eight hours.
That's right.
Let me find this session IDs.
Session ID equals no.
With this session we have one trace
and the trace will allow us
to map what's happening behind the scenes.
We are already depicted
what's going on in the code.
And let me open this and let me close
this little window is yes,
I don't want to see that.
Now the trace console within
AgentCore Observability,
as you can see has a tri
and also it has a timeline.
So you can see what's going on.
The first thing is that
it was a post invocation.
Then we have, we grab the prompts
from each of the four
prompts that we're using.
Then we invoke the swarm,
then we invoke the FSI loan advisor.
Then we go into a loop
in which we can hand over
the request to the
agents within the swarm.
And then we invoke the model,
which was Anthropic Haiku 4.5.
And then we can see that
we execute the event loops
for each of the models.
We can drill into the specific
of the modeling vacation.
Like for example, this
modeling vocation right here
was completed in two seconds,
193 tokens input and a
thousand tokens input
and a hundred tokens of output.
And then we can start seeing what is the,
I would say the system prompt.
You are a main FSI loan advisor.
You work with some specialist agent
to help customers delegate
specialist as you need.
We're going to see like available
a specialist rate checker
loan calculator eligibility.
And also you can see the trajectory.
This is quite cool because you
can see it in a graphic way.
What the flow of the invocation,
it's what's happening.
So the first time we
receive the invoke room time
AgentCore, we receive that into a post.
Then we grab all the prompts,
then we book the loan agent
and then we book the eligibility.
As you can see the loop cycle,
the minutes that were required
in order to complete this request.
Any questions? Doubt so far? Yes? Yes.
- [Audience Member] Are the events
on the previous page the same one?
So would be passed in the
memory if you had it configured.
- [Gabriel] Ah, perfect.
Now the memory has its
own observability space.
So if you, in this case we
don't have the memory enabled
for the sake of the-
The purpose of the demonstration.
But in AgentCore Observability
you're going to see that we have agents
and also we have memory observability.
So if we had observability memory enabled,
we will see like all the
events for short term
and long term memory right here.
- [Audience Member] So
would you see the breakdown
of the different strategies
and everything as well?
- [Gabriel] Yes. You will see
the breakdown of the strategy,
what's been stored in
each of the memories.
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
but you see it though?
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
- [Gabriel] Yes.
Because in sessions then you can see the,
that information from the
memory, from the detail.
We don't have a memory right now.
If configure he will see it right here.
And metrics from that.
(presenter speak indistinctly)
Okay, now let's try
to fix another one
that's quite common also.
And let's ask the model for...
Let's see the last one.
Now let me ask the agent,
let me refresh this
to have the latest version, version 29.
Now, regarding what is
the current interest?
Interest rates for a 30...
(Gabriel speaks indistinctly)
Okay.
We can see once again the
logs that are being invoked.
- [Luis] And also something
that we would like
to have here is for example,
that the interest rate can
be evaluated by the agent
and provide a different rate
according to the customers
and allow them to obtain a credit in a
or a loan in a few minutes.
So that's why we have
created different agents here
and we're going to talk about
the multi-agent architecture at end.
- [Gabriel] Okay.
Now there is a slight
issue with this agent.
As you can see the information
we have, it's outdated.
It's from 2023.
This is something that might happen
because of the maintenance
of the knowledge basis
in order to ingest basically
to process new information.
And also this is as loose mention
because this is an agent
that provides advice,
financial advisory,
this can misguide the
customer to take a decision
because the this
information does not reflect
the actual reality.
Okay, now I'm going to grab
the session ID once again
and now we are going back into
the CloudWatch observability
and the AgentCore Observability.
And I'm going to search for this session.
Session ID.
Okay?
And the objective in this part
is that within the
traces we're going to see
in the trajectory the
requests that are being
performed towards the knowledge base.
Okay?
Now,
let's move back all back to the end.
And then...
- [Luis] How many knowledge
base do we have here?
- [Gabriel] We have just one
for the sake of the session.
But the important thing is that,
if you've had many others knowledge bases,
which is a common architecture,
you will see that,
why did the agent start
selecting one over the other?
And you can see the even the
chunks that were retrieved
by the request from retrieve,
retrieve from the knowledge base.
So let me check if I can find retrieve.
This one here.
Okay, now this is
something that as you said,
I'm going to select retrieve
and it didn't bring any information.
Okay?
When I show the x-ray configuration,
the default configuration is to ingest,
sorry, to index 1% of the traces.
Okay?
You're seeing the overall trajectory.
But if you set the value
as the default that it is,
you may encounter this,
that not all the information
is being shown into the traces.
Okay?
Now there is a trade off,
if you increase the value,
it's going to give a pro
it's going to cost more
because the number of events
that are being processed will increase.
- [Luis] Yeah, in that case
you can decide if you want
to have a hundred percent
of the logs being ingested
and index it or if you
prefer in case you have
a production environment,
choose less than that.
Do you have a question?
- [Audience Member] How does
it decide if (speaks faintly).
- [Gabriel] I'm sorry, what?
- [Audience Member] How does it decide
what to record if it's not set?
Like what's the algorithm
or how is it determined?
What events that persisted or whatnot?
- [Gabriel] It's a
random sample basically.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
- [Gabriel] A sampling.
- [Audience Member] So, you
could get lucky on some runs
and you could get unlucky on other one.
- [Luis] Exactly.
- [Gabriel] Exactly.
Okay. Exactly. Okay.
That just as it happened right here. Okay.
Now I'm going to fix this
real quick and basically,
I'm going to move to the knowledge base.
In this case,
this is the knowledge base
that we have for this session
and this is the source
bucket that we have configure
and I'm going to replace
all those files in a second.
So let me grab the...
- [Luis] So this is something
that is very complex
for our current customers is,
is how to have updated
all the knowledge bases.
So that's something that
we should see in this case.
We have Bedrock knowledge
bases that are using
as a source and S3 bucket.
And what Gabo is going to do here,
is to update those files.
You have a question?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
- [Luis] Now, let me go there
to see if I can hear you better also
for the rest of the people.
Can you please say that again?
- [Audience Member] Yeah, I was asking
if the session ID is persisted,
the same session ideas
persisted across like,
if you have a gateway
set up or memory set up
and you have traces
enabled through all of 'em.
Is it a single session ID?
You can connect them together.
- [Luis] Yeah, that session ID
it corresponds to the
AgentCore runin session.
So for the AgentCore runin,
it's going to be the same.
If you have a different
session from the memory site,
you are also going, we're
going to have the same ID.
- [Gabriel] Exactly.
Basically because you
can set the session ID
from the client side,
you can persist the same session ID.
Now the default timeout, it's
15 minutes if I recall well.
Up to eight hours.
So when the run time die,
basically you need to...
If you create another set
with the same session ID,
it's going to be another
runtime environment.
Okay, now I'm fixing this
and while this syncs,
this was a quick fix.
I want to move over to
another theme in the code
that might be useful for you folks.
Also in the, I would say to optimize for,
that's basically that in this situation,
as you have seen most of our interaction
is orchestrator specialized agent.
So basically we have a
full mesh environment.
Let me see if I can draw
something real quick right here.
So we have something like this and then-
Then disconnect with this one
and disconnect with this one
and this with this one and this,
I mean it's a full mesh of communication.
Now this is this the architecture
that we have right now with
our agent in this part,
let me show you where it is.
The AgentCore entry point is it's a swarm
with an entry point
with a max hopes of 20.
But we can aim to simplify
this in a another iteration.
That's basically if we switch to a,
for example a workflow orchestrator
or basically to move to a,
like a principle agent
and a subordinate agent,
we can remove all those connections
with simpler architecture
and also that can simplify the interaction
between the agents and can decrease
the agent times response.
- [Luis] Okay, very good.
So we only have three minutes to finish.
Something that we want
to show you here is that
you can use AgentCore
to deploy your agents,
but in case you want to
use any specific component,
for example if you decided
only to use observability,
you can use that you
were asking about memory.
So from the AgentCore side
we can have logs and traces
and metrics from runtime memory
and gateway that are ingested
inside AgentCore Observability.
You can see those, that
information in CloudWatch.
But if you prefer to use
another observability tool,
you can send the logs and information
because we have the OpenTelemetry format.
Also different concepts that
Gabo was showing us here
is that we have the session ID,
is like the main data
but from that you can have also traces,
spans, sub-spans that allow you
to know what's happening with the agent
and with each interaction
that users are having there.
Some of the key metrics and signals
we were seeing here three different issues
but there are different
issues that you are going
to face when you have
an agent in production.
So here we are showing you
where you can find the issue.
So if you have an issue
related to latency,
we have a specific matrix for that.
Or if you are having issues
with invalid schemas,
you can go to the logs
and check user errors.
Also, we have good
information about token.
I know these kind of projects
are very price sensitive.
I have for example a customer
that has a good use case
for agent AI for agents,
but the problem is that this doesn't
is giving their profit
because it very expensive.
So you can trace here the cost
and verify it is good for you.
- [Gabriel] Exactly.
- [Luis] And finally,
we want to provide some of the resources.
If you haven't used
AgentCore started toolkit,
I fully recommend to use it
because you are going to deploy
an agent in a few minutes.
You are going to understand more
that we were showing you here.
Also, if you want to see code
samples about how to use,
for example, other frameworks to send data
to AgentCore Observability,
you can do that.
We were using Strands but
that's not the only option.
And also if you want to go
and dive deep in AgentCore,
this is a good workshop that you can check
for the component that
it's better for you.
I have for example some customers
that prefer only using the gateway.
That's okay.
You can see what all the
components are there.
I dunno Gabo, if you want
to add something there.
- [Gabriel] No, I think that's it.
- [Luis] Okay.
So thank you again for
your attendancy here.
We are going to have a survey
at the end of the session.
I think you have there in the app.
So if you have any questions,
we are going to be here.
Thank you again for your time.
Thank you so much for being here.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
Thank you and appreciate it.
(audience applauds)